this morning we're looking at how one
car accident can result in more than
700 thousand dollars in medical bills
even with medical and car insurance in
our continuing our continuing bill of
the month partnership with kaiser health
news and
npr we examine unexpected medical costs
when mark gottlieb was hit by another
car while driving he damaged four
vertebrae and smashed several teeth
despite having a quarter of a million
dollars in personal injury protection
from his auto insurer and medical
insurance
his medical insurance was unable to
cover the remaining balance
a car basically came out of nowhere went
through a red light
thought i was going to die mark godley
was injured in a car accident in january
of 2019
his geico car insurance plan covered 250
000
of medical care after physical therapy
and other treatments that geico covered
mark needed spinal surgery he thought he
would be covered by the money left in
his plan there was no pain compared to
when the bills came
but the hospital and surgeons bills
totaled over 700 thousand dollars
geico negotiated both bills down
substantially and
paid more than a hundred fifty thousand
toward gottlieb's charges
before his plan was exhausted leaving
him on the hook for about
ninety thousand dollars for the
surgeon's bill i figured it would be
a quarter million dollars is a lot of
insurance it didn't make any sense how
that could happen
extremely blindsided godley submitted
the surgeon bill's balance to aetna
his health insurance aetna told us that
it offered to pay the standard rate of
care
under gottlieb's policy but because the
surgeon and his office were
out of network he would still owe over
four thousand dollars
to meet his deductible so he withdrew
his request
for aetna's coverage after this
experience
he fears seeking any additional
treatment to help with his
existing back pain even from an
in-network
doctor i am doing absolutely nothing
i'll take extra strength tylenol
you know the last thing i want to see
happen is i go to the doctor regarding
this
and i end up getting some humongous bill
i have a huge fear because of what
happened
hudson regional hospital said in a
statement that it charged the state
mandated fee for all applicable services
to mr gottlieb
and for the balance of his care the
charges were reasonable
the surgeon and his office bergen pain
management have not
pursued gottlieb for the almost 90
thousand dollar
outstanding bill joining us now is dr
elizabeth rosenthal
the editor-in-chief of kaiser health
news doctor good morning thanks for
being with us as if back pain wasn't bad
enough
this is excruciating what can we learn
from mr gottlieb's story
well um there are a lot of things you
can learn that health insurance and car
insurance protection don't play very
well together first of all
and when you get in a car crash there
are there are just
endless minefields and mr gottlieb poor
mr gottlieb
hit almost all of them yeah when you say
they don't play very well together what
do you mean how does auto insurance
work versus health insurance here well
the first thing to know is if you're in
an accident and you have
personal injury protection insurance
through your auto insurer
that kicks in first so that pays the
first part of the bill
but they work really differently first
of all they have
smaller networks in some states
including new jersey they have set
rates they pay for procedures but if
if the surgeon and the hospital add a
few things
that aren't on the rate list they can
charge whatever they want
the sky's the limit and that's what
happened to mr
gottlieb and then when it kicked over
into his health insurance
the health insurer had different
networks so the doctors who'd been
treating him
were out of network so once again no
help from
your health insurance you say if it's
not an emergency
procedure patients should get price
estimates
from their medical facilities explain
why that's so important
well i say they should try because at
least and get it in writing and don't
get it you know a lot of people will
tell me
well you know i went to i called the
billing office and they said don't worry
and in fact mr gottlieb did ask someone
at the doctor's office and they said oh
it will never
you know go blow through a quarter of a
million dollars but it did
so you have to get it in writing from
the finance office
and then at least you have something to
fight with look i have an estimate here
in my hand
so honor it several states require
personal
injury protection insurance if your
state doesn't require it what should you
do
well it really puts consumers in a bind
because every state is different
pip as they call it it has some
advantages
and that it's first dollar insurance
that means it will pay
immediately no co-pays no deductibles
but it doesn't it tends not to be
big insurance so if you're in a huge car
accident and you need surgery as mr
gottlieb did
you'll exhaust that pip insurance and it
will have to kick over to your health
insurance
and then you have to know that the
networks coordinate and you know when
you get in a car accident you don't know
is it going to be a big one or am i just
going to have like
some stitches so it puts patients once
again in
a totally untenable position and it's
just not
fair no it's not dr elizabeth rosenthal
thank you so much